本期节目由淘宝闪购冠名播出。
看球上淘宝闪购 点外卖更优惠。
嗨各位早上好呀 今天是2026年的6月25号星期四。
这里是生动早咖啡 我是来自生动活泼的梦一。
LULULAM的哪些竞争对手想要进一步的拓展中国市场。
字节为什么要在免费的豆包之外 推出收费的豆包专业版。
今天节目就会和你一起来了解这些问题。
当然今天是个周四 节目的最后依然是我们每周四的世界杯特条。
今天世界杯特条想和你聊聊足球球衣。
如果你上抖音会发现 非法官方旗舰店已经上线了。
包括包包挂式 钥匙扣 还有吉祥物手办在内的各种世界杯周边。
但是点开销量榜单你会看到 各国球衣的月销量已经超过了万件。
是销量第二的吉祥物挂件的三倍多。
而且截止到我们这期节目解稿的时候。
葡萄牙队还有阿根廷队的球衣都出现了部分尺码断货的情况。
通常来说人们选购球衣 为的是支持自己喜欢的球队。
但现如今足球球衣在国内正在像球鞋一样变成新的社交语言。
那么足球球衣是如何成为年轻人的日程穿搭 甚至是时尚单品的。
我们先来了解一下最近的商业科技动态。
节目最后的世界杯特条 我们会和你一同走进足球球衣的世界。
豆包专业版正式上线收费。
6月24号字节旗下的AI应用豆包推出了。
基于豆包2.1系列大模型的付费服务豆包专业版。
豆包专业版采用了三级阶梯的定价方案。
免费分别是68元、200元和500元。
豆包表示专业版面向软件开发、数据分析和设计等复杂的办公场景。
提供更高的使用额度和全新的办公任务模式。
同时免费版用户的日常功能和额度保持不变。
不过根据36颗的报道。
字节今年暂时不会把付费用户的比例当做核心的考核指标。
他们的短期运营目标也不是大规模的增加用户。
要验证专业版的功能价值能否获得市场认可。
根据《界面新闻》6月23日的报道。
Deepsea近期新成立的Honest团队正在大规模招聘。
团队负责人崔天逸在社交媒体上表示。
这个新成立的部门人才缺口很大。
他每天都在面试，还在各个平台张贴招聘广告。
不过岗位要求当中标注。
需要候选人有良好的中文沟通能力。
也被外界解读为，不招外国人。
团队负责人表示
这只是工作语言的要求并不意味着排斥外国求职者。
Honest团队是Deepsea内部新成立的AI智能体团队。
想要把大模型能力。
转化为能够实际执行任务的智能体产品。
有行业人士把Honest称为大模型的脚手架。
包括工具调用，上下文工程，技艺管理等系统工程手段。
可以在不改变模型架构和参数的基础上。
把模型的能力最大程度的发挥出来。
阿里和腾讯收缩游戏业务。
根据36颗6月23号的报道。
阿里巴巴集团正在考虑出售旗下的游戏业务。
灵溪护鱼
他们已经接触了多家钱在买方。
交易估值预计在70亿-90亿元之间。
灵溪护鱼最知名的产品是。
三国制战略版
这款策略游戏长期占据着IOS。
畅销榜的钱时
年流水的峰值可以达到数十亿元。
根据36颗的报道。
灵溪护鱼在阿里内部的管理体系。
经历了多次变化
最近一次的调整
是向集团的首席财务官汇报。
而管理权从业务转向财务。
通常也就意味着
核心业务失去了增长动力和竞争力。
而阿里已经明确将AI作为核心的投入。
同时兼守电商和及时零售等业务。
通过出售成熟的游戏资产。
可以将更多的资源投入AI和云计算。
另外，根据彭博同一天的报道。
腾讯正在重新评估。
他们在全球游戏行业进行的投资。
也计划退出部分海外游戏工作室。
大疆Pocket 4P正式开售。
6月23日的晚间。
大疆全新的云台相机。
Osmo Pocket 4P正式开售。
多个销售渠道迅速进入售信的状态。
在二手交易平台上。
Pocket 4P标准套装的成交价。
一度涨到了5000元左右。
比官方发售价贵了1000多元。
CBN Data的分析认为。
Pocket 4P的发布节奏和定价。
和大疆过去的产品策略有明显的不同。
饮食在6月初发布了云台相机Luna Elton。
5天之后，大疆就推出了Pocket 4P。
定价要比饮食低200块。
我们也在之前的节目当中介绍过。
两家公司还在美国打起了专利战。
不过36颗的分析认为。
这两家公司的竞争。
让曾经只有专业摄影机才有的功能。
被下放到了3000元价位的产品上。
未来随着OPPO、Vivo等厂商的加入。
云台相机市场
可能会迎来更多的创新。
和更低的价格
Meta发布自由品牌智能眼镜。
6月23日，Meta发布了。
以自由品牌命名的新系列智能眼镜。
Meta Glossus。
起售价格是299美元。
比之前的雷鹏第二代智能眼镜。
便宜了80美元
新的系列包括
三款不同的造型
其中一款
与美国名人Kali Jenner合作设计。
售价是399美元。
不过Meta的眼镜。
仍然是由Meta的合作伙伴。
雷鹏母公司
伊士露露徐卡生产。
Meta可穿戴设备部门负责人表示。
他们曾经和伊士露露徐卡。
一起寻找适合低价定位的品牌。
但是没有找到合适的品牌。
最终决定用Meta自己的名字。
另外Meta还透露。
他们正在考虑推出。
不带摄像头的版本。
只保留用来通话
听音乐
和信息AI交互的音频功能。
这样就可以进一步的降低价格。
不过智能眼镜赛道。
也正在变得越来越拥挤。
Continpoint Research的数据显示。
Meta目前在智能眼镜市场的份额。
超过80%
竞争对手在加速入场。
SNAP一周之前。
发布了售价
2000多美元的AR眼镜。
苹果也计划推出类似的产品。
孙正义看衰太空数据中心。
根据CNBC6月24日的报道。
SpaceX在上市不到两周之后。
就完成了250亿美元的债券发行。
他们表示
募集的资金将主要用于。
偿还此前的200亿美元贷款。
SpaceX在6月12日登陆纳斯达克。
上市的前两天
股价大涨超过5成。
市值一度超过亚马逊和微软。
但是随后他们的股价连续下跌。
目前SpaceX的市值。
在2万亿美元左右。
根据CNBC的报道。
SpaceX对资金的需求很大。
公司自成立以来
累计亏损了400亿美元。
除了在地面投入AI基础设施。
马斯克还提出了
在太空建造数据中心的构想。
SpaceX和亚马逊创始人。
被所思旗下的蓝色起源。
都已经宣布了相关的计划。
不过这个方向
遇到了来自于同行的质疑。
在6月23日
阮英集团创始人孙正义表示。
在太空建造数据中心。
没有太大的意义
他认为太空数据中心的主要优势。
是电力成本低
但是电费在数据中心运营成本里。
只占一小部分
芯片等等硬件才是大头。
把设备送上太空的运输费用。
后续维护成本
以及通信延迟
都会抵消节省下来的电费。
孙正义表示
在AI竞争当中
未来几年远比10年之后。
可能发生的事情更加重要。
阮英将会专注在地面。
建设大规模的数据中心算力。
66 lemon的竞争对手动作不断。
根据路透社6月23号的报道。
运动休闲品牌Alo Yoga的母公司。
已经把旗下批发T-shirt的业务。
出售给了第三方
不过交易还没有完成。
研究机构Global Data Retail认为。
玻璃T-shirt批发业务。
能够让Alo Yoga。
成为一个更加聚焦的。
高端运动休闲公司。
公司的价格也会更加简单。
未来IPO或者是融资。
也会更方便
2023年Alo Yoga。
想要以大约100亿美元的估值。
引入外部投资
但当时T-shirt批发业务。
增加了投资者理解公司的难度。
最终没有达成交易。
目前Alo Yoga在全球。
拥有超过150家门店。
业务也已经从鱼家服饰。
扩展到户夫、协旅。
还有美容产品
就在上周
Alo Yoga在国内的社交媒体上。
统一发布了第一条名字叫。
你好中国的推送
界民新闻认为
他们可能已经在加速。
中国区的开店计划。
另外根据《华尔街日报》
6月23号的报道。
Lulu Lemon的另一个竞争对手。
美国品牌Viori。
也正在加速国际市场的扩张。
Viori总裁表示。
在中国
他们目前有8家门店。
目标市到2027年年底。
开到20家门店
重点布局上海还有北京。
Viori这个品牌起步于加州。
最初是以男性运动服饰。
打开市场的
目前也在拓展女性产品线。
中国家店品牌
抢占东南亚市场
根据《日经》新闻。
6月22号的报道。
中国家店品牌过去五年。
在东南亚的市场份额持续攀升。
已经从2020年的17%。
提升到了2025年的大约21%。
其中空调品类的增长。
特别突出
市场份额在五年时间。
提升了10%
在印尼中国空调品牌的份额。
翻了一倍多
超过了长期领先的日本品牌。
马来西亚的一家零售商。
表示中国品牌在2000年左右。
进入马来西亚时
主要吸引的还是
预算有限的消费者。
但是在2010年前后。
中国厂商在产品质量。
和设计上加大投入。
同时中国智能手机。
在当地的成功
也改变了当地的消费者。
对中国产品的认知。
年轻消费者购买家店的时候。
更加看重性价比和功能。
也有印尼的零售商。
表示中国品牌的产品功能。
和日韩产品相当
价格却便宜2-4成。
新品上市的速度更快。
还会针对热带气候。
做本地化的适配
与此同时
中国家店企业
也在东南亚加速建厂。
美地在印尼的西藻娃。
建立了年产能
超过200万台冰箱的。
全自动工厂
在泰国
设立了最大的
海外生产基地和区域总部。
海尔泽把泰国定位为。
进入东南亚的桥头堡。
已经连续多年
在泰国空调市场
保持着领先地位
欢迎来到今天的
世界杯特条
这个夏天
足球球衣的热度
随着世界杯比赛的进行。
也在不断的攀升
北京三里团线下商店。
给球衣印字的门店门口。
排起了长队
上海星天地
一场复古足球世纪。
一下子涌进了几千人。
而在小红书平台上。
关于足球球衣穿搭的搜索量。
也在持续的飙升
世界杯球衣
本来是各国对付
或者是球迷
表达自己的周边
为什么现在
成为了当下
年轻人的日常穿搭。
甚至是时尚单品了呢？
原因之一
球衣在比赛当中
最容易被看见
一场足球比赛下来。
人们看见的
不仅仅是球员的表现。
球衣上的图案和品牌。
也会随着那些
精彩的瞬间
被一次次的定格
有行业媒体认为
在球场上
电视转播中
社交媒体上
甚至在电子游戏中。
球衣都是一支球队。
最能够被看见的标志。
于是球衣也从
赛事周边
逐渐地发展成为
一个由运动品牌
赛事IP
授权零售
以及内容平台
共同推动的
全球化时尚消费品类。
Vogue Business注意到。
其实在2022年。
卡塔尔世界杯之前。
球衣加牛仔裤
加复古运动鞋的
所谓Block Core传达。
就已经在
抖音小红书平台上走红。
而今年世界杯球衣。
设计最明显的一个趋势。
就是复古
投报研究院
等等机构的数据显示。
在世界杯赛事的
带动之下
预计2026年
国内复古足球
相关消费的市场规模。
又往突破50亿元。
原因之二
中国年轻人
拥有更多球衣的
选择自由
根据
三连生活周刊的分析。
中国对缺席世界杯。
反倒是带来了一个。
意外的效果
就是使得中国年轻人。
拥有了一种
其他足球强国年轻人。
没有的自由
由于没有必须
支持主队的期待
中国的年轻人
反倒是可以更加纯粹的。
出于个人的
审美或喜好来做选择。
像是非法官方
旗舰店的买家评论里。
也有不少关于
不同球队球衣的
穿搭分享
而且世界杯球衣
也有着越来越
明显的审美倾向
比如法国对客场球衣。
拥有薄荷绿的底色。
同色的线条
它所致敬的就是
法国送给美国的礼物。
自由女神像
再比如哥伦比亚
客场球衣
用深蓝和浅蓝
分别象征
太平洋和加勒比海。
两条蓝色之带
把两片海洋交織在一起。
原因之三
球衣具有收藏价值。
一件球衣之所以成为经典。
部分原因
也在于它所经历的。
经典时刻
而实践的流逝
也会改变
我们对一件足球球衣的看法。
和欣赏方式
这也就构成了
球衣的收藏价值
最极端的例子
是马拉多纳
1986年世界杯。
上帝之首的那件球衣。
2022年在苏福比。
拍出了700多万英镑的高价。
吉尼斯世界纪录
把它列为
拍卖成交价最高的足球球衣。
不过对于国内的球衣。
收藏爱好者来说
想要逃换一件老球衣。
并不是很容易
由于国内缺少
收藏版球衣的交易渠道。
而且市场上
还充置着倒版球衣。
所以真假也难以辨别。
那这个夏天
你购买世界杯球衣了吗？
如果是的话
你的球衣
又是属于哪支队伍的呢？
欢迎在我们的评论区。
大家一起来聊聊
说起看球赛
你南海里
第一时间想到的是什么？
是深夜酒吧突然爆发的欢呼。
是夏夜烧烤摊的烟火器。
还是堆满茶几的薯片辣条。
啤酒配小龙虾的畅快。
但是今年似乎有些特别。
赛程从凌晨1点到中午12点。
过去独属于深夜的看球仪式。
今年被拉长
成了一整天的狂欢。
凌晨3点
你可以约上朋友
啤酒烧烤小龙虾
提前备齐
边吃边等比赛开场。
早上六七点
也可以一边就着油条豆浆。
一边追着精彩对决。
到了中午直接点分外卖。
把午餐时间
变成你的川鼠光赛时间。
下午饭困想提神
就再来一杯咖啡
光赛热情持续满格。
不管你追哪个时段的赛事。
无论是夜宵下酒菜。
还是临时饮料早午餐。
上淘宝散购
想吃什么点什么？
搜大历省
拼团点外卖
低至五折起
比赛精彩开场
美味同步到位
今年足球季
你的最佳光赛搭配是什么？
欢迎在评论区
分享你的光赛套餐。
我们将从互动厅友中。
抽取三位
报销一顿看球外卖。
淘宝散购
让每一场球都更对味。
今天的生动早咖啡。
就到这里
我们明天再会